welcome to GameSpot gameplay where we
talk a little bit and then show you some
clean gameplay so you can make up your
own mind for years I have watched
battlefield players not understand the
power of the smoke grenade the main
reason of course being that for most of
battlefield existence smoke grenade use
has not been properly rewarded with XP
that gets players up the old grind tree
that may be about to change
now in the community test environment
battlefield 1 in the name of the SAR is
showing off new specializations
specializations are new to battlefield
but one in particular is and is making a
large impact it's a concealed rescue
perk that makes down squad mates within
20 metres of a medic drop a smoke
grenade so you can revive them under
concealment it's a huge quality of life
boost for medic similar to when you
could finally walk up to the support
class and take ammo from them with the
press of a button rather than having to
whip out a pistol and make a more formal
request I'm sure not everyone will be
thrilled by all that smoke on the
battlefield
so let me know how you feel about the
new specializations coming to
Battlefield 1 be sure to leave a like or
consider subscribing to our Channel
let's look at some gameplay of what
concealed rescue does to the battlefield
so I stood up to some flaky for this
Camelot yes the hip
Aviano destined for
we have lost objective duck
sorry Sonya [ __ ] pardon
diviner we have lost objective part we
have taken objective death
[Music]
location
[Music]
heads on the toilet it's cardio
I see medieval on
yeah yes - okay
returned to the combat area returned to
the combat area
yep yes the dish